The Third World War.
That's how one Russian soldier describes
what he's seeing on the ground
in Ukraine
in a new recording
just in exclusively to CNN.
CNN has obtained
this intercepted phone conversation
between the Russian soldier
and his girlfriend.
Listen to this part
It's World War Three out there.
If they didn't
bring in the mobilized soldiers
and if we didn't go there,
they'd already be here.
We would be totally anybody.
They would hammer away at Moscow
and Yekaterinburg.
Know they'd hammer everything.
It's a scary
The soldier says that his unit of 96
96 has already lost
more than half its people.
More than half 50.
And he says that it is clear to him
that those in charge
don't care about the troops.
The commander's position
was hit by a rocket
for Take America in credibly.
He managed to gather up his unit
in just 30 minutes
and they all retreated
further from the shelling.
But us we were totally goddammit.
Are we not human beings?
I don't know some guys here.
Soon we will just leave and go to him
and go to him.
To the commander of the battalion.
And we'll just shoot him.
Nobody will even investigate the
fighting.
Just go shoot
the commander of his battalion.
It is it is unbelievable to hear this.
And yet we have heard
and seen
we've shown you
this incredible discontent
and unrest among the Russian fighters.
In fact,
we're hearing it
yet again tonight
in another newly obtained
video
believed to have been filmed recently
in Russia at a training ground.
Listen, to this.
We have been held rifles
for the past two weeks
and came today
to the training grounds
to throw grenades.
We were there.
They told us
they didn't have any grenades
and they didn't have a bus
for us to return.
So we walked from the training grounds
back to here, ten kilometers.
It took ten kilometers to get back.
We came from there to here.
How can we fight along officers
who are like this?
They would sell us off their Ukraine
Matthew Chance
has much more on
all of this OUTFRONT in Kiev.
And I want to warn you
that some of the images you will see in
his report may be disturbing
as Russia's
military highlights
its barrage of Ukraine.
CNN has obtained exclusive recordings
of a Russian soldier
describing the brutal reality of life
on the frontlines.
We'll come up with
pretty little
given that
the commander's position was shelled.
So he packed up and moved further back.
But what about us? Aren't we humans? To
the Russian soldier was recorded
phoning his girlfriend
back home,
according to Ukrainian intelligence,
and telling her candidly
about the severe military
setbacks suffered in the two months
since he arrived to her to.
We had 96 people in our unit
but now there are less than 50.
The thing is nice to hear that you know
you don't know what to expect here.
Sometimes there's friendly
fire and idiots shoot at us
because they don't see our coordinates
but it is advancing Ukrainian forces
that are the major threats,
compounding low morale
with high bloodshed.
Ukrainian officials
now reacting to this extraordinary video
of Russian soldiers
apparently surrendering geolocated by CNN
to a recently liberated town
in eastern Ukraine.
Now I have the phone number.
Come on, out one by one.
A Ukrainian soldier calls out.
Then a short burst of gunfire
before the video cuts off.
Later, a Ukrainian military drone shows
what appears to be the same men
in pools of blood.
The Kremlin says it's an execution,
but Ukraine says the soldiers
feigns surrender
and fired
the Ukrainians,
accusing Russia of its own war crime.
No one disputes the horror.
It's unclear
if the dead Russians were regular troops
or deployed as part of the Kremlin's
partial mobilization
seen here earlier this year.
But the soldier recorded on the phone
indicates he was recently conscripted.
Complaining bitterly
at being unable to leave the warzone.
Market is all,
and they're being mobilized as crap.
Nobody can go home
until Putin announces the order.
There's no way to return this issue then
to bring your political thinking.
And if we weren't here,
they the Ukrainians
would already be at our borders.
They would show Moscow, Yekaterinburg,
show everything.
And that constant
threat of Ukrainian attack
is having a terrifying effect.
In particular, drone strikes
which appear to have left the soldier
particularly nervous. Nevertheless,
my nerves are on edge.
I'm afraid of every wrestle,
every bang,
every click makes me drop to the ground.
In Russian controlled eastern Ukraine.
The funerals are underway
for more of those
killed on the brutal front line
that Ukrainian officials insist
would never have happened.
But for Russia's war
Well, Aaron,
the big change over the past
couple of days here in Ukraine
has been the plunging
temperatures
with the first snow
of the winter covering the ground.
This as Russia
continuing its missile strikes
against energy
infrastructure targets,
causing power
cuts and shortages
Across the country,
Russia may be on the defensive,
but it is
at this point far from defeated Erin.
Thank you very much.
Matthew Chance
with that exclusive report
from Kiev tonight.
I want to go now
to John Brennan, the former CIA director
and the author of Undaunted My Fight
Against America's
Enemies at Home and Abroad,
which is now available in paperback
as well.
Director, thank you for your time.
You know,
when you hear this phone conversation
and you know,
the full conversation and lots of detail,
what do you
take away from it?
Well, Erin,
I think
as those conversations
indicate, as well
as Matthew is reporting,
Russian military operations on
the ground in Ukraine
are in complete disarray.
Even after nine months of fighting,
they still have not been able
to coordinate
a lot of their operations, their ground
and air operations.
And it does seem as though
the morale of Russian forces
is at an all time low
and they're sending in these new recruits
without sufficient training,
without sufficient weapons,
and they're basically serving as
cannon fodder.
And so I can understand that
those Russian soldiers
who are calling home,
I'm sure that most of them
are very worried
about their their future, their lives.
And I can just expect
that this is just going to continue
and get worse
for them in the coming months.
Yeah.
I mean, an interesting, you know,
sort of the mutiny when you saying, well,
if this continues this way, you know,
we'll just go shoot
our commanding officer
to actually even say such a thing.
I want to play one more clip
from that specific
intercepted phone call director
between the soldier and his girlfriend.
This is what happened
after he told her that only 50 of the 96
people in his unit were still alive.
He then said this
said to work with them.
So there are only those 50 people there
with you in the forest.
Are there more you?
Of course there are more
people a lot of prisoners.
People from PMCs, huh?
PMC, private military company.
They came here on contract.
It's funny.
Be careful there, please.
Now I'm trying
he said expletive loads of prisoners
and mercenaries. Right.
So more than half his unit is killed.
And there's this unbelievable number
of prisoners
and mercenaries
more than the actual military
is the clear implication.
Director, what does this say to you
about Putin standing?
If this is his fighting force right now,
what appears to be left are prisoners
that they've released and and mercenaries
Well, it shows that he's
running out of options
to try to reverse his fortunes
on the battlefield
with conventional military means.
He is opting to empty the prisons
for Russia and also use the Wagner group.
This is the mercenary group
and sending them in,
but they're also getting chewed up
by the Ukrainian forces.
And so it's clear
that he's going to be relying
more and more on these long range attacks
and going after critical infrastructure,
trying to destroy the electric grids,
as well as the water stations,
other things
to try to freeze the Ukrainians out
and try to undermine their morale.
But if anything,
I think it's the Russian morale
that continues to plummet.
Well,
so you mentioned critical infrastructure.
And obviously you've got the largest
nuclear power
plant in Europe, in Ukraine.
We've talked a lot about it.
But now, once again,
moving to the front burner,
all this fighting is still happening
around Zapper, Asia's nuclear plant.
Russia Russia, state media
tonight
director now
saying that the plant is, quote,
at risk of a nuclear accident.
The head of Russia's
nuclear energy agency today
claiming that, quote,
It is obvious that Kiev
considers a small nuclear
incident acceptable.
Do you think, Director,
that Russia is now more specifically
setting Ukraine up
for another false flag
that could sort of open
the floodgates to nuclear activity?
Very possibly
in the middle of a war zone?
And there's shelling
coming from both sides.
And there are a lot of parts
of that nuclear
reactor complex
that could, in fact, be vulnerable
to the shelling.
Radioactive material could be leaked out.
But also, Russia has been waiving
that nuclear saber
over the past several months
and saying that the Ukrainians
were going to use
some type of dirty bomb as a pretext
for escalation.
So I am concerned that the rhetoric now
once again
is focusing
on the nuclear reactor plant in freezer.
The fighting around
the area is increasing,
which means that the what has been
the largest nuclear plant in Europe
could, in fact,
be the site
of a devastating nuclear disaster
that could have
far reaching implications.
Hopefully,
the reactors are
not going to be breached.
But given the light,
the fighting that's going
on, given
the fact that
some of the electric power
going to the complex is being cut off,
and you need to maintain that electricity
in order
to keep those cooling systems running.
So it is at a very worrisome stage
in terms of where that reactor so
future stands.